bonjour à tous alors tout d'abord merci
beaucoup d'être là je pense que je vais
soulager plusieurs personnes si je
commence par la définition du transmédia
alors le transmédia c'est le fait de
créer des univers sur plusieurs supports
et tous ces supports donc tous ces
médias une fois mis bout-à-bout créer
une histoire qui se veut à la fois
cohérente et complémentaire
alors chaque histoire transmédia a bien
un début pour nous ça a été la websérie
alors je pense que plus tôt nous
expliquer ce qu'est la websérie je vous
donner un exemple avec deux vidéos l'une
qui date de 2000 on pardonnerait ce que
vous allez voir est une autre de 2017 et
ensuite on en reparle et là j'ai pu sur
le petit bouton
à l'époque j'étais maigre et 2010
une petite évolution évidemment il ya
encore beaucoup de choses à apprendre
mais cette évolution m'a quand même
permis de faire du transmédia mon métier
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que il
ya certains principes qui reviennent
assez régulièrement
le premier d'entre eux sur internet
c'est qu'il faut donner pour recevoir
à partir du principe que vous êtes un
jeune créatif que vous soyez
autodidactes ou que vous sortez d'une
école c'est à peu près la même chose
votre premier réflexe si vous voulez un
budget c'est peut-être aller voir un
producteur ou un éditeur ou une marque
comme ça se fait beaucoup sur internet
et là il ya peu de chances qu'ils
investissent sur vous si vous n'avez
rien créé au préalable ou alors vous
allez peut-être vous dire ok je vais
choisir l'autofinancement
d'autofinancement vous allez voir les
internautes vous allez dire hey salut
j'ai super g des pleins de projets etc
mais si vous n'avez rien publier au
préalable il ya peu de choses qu'ils
investissent sur vous également qu'il
faut confier un budget parce que sur
internet les règles ne sont pas les
mêmes que dans le circuit traditionnel
sur internet avant qu'on vous fasse
confiance avant que vous puissiez
espérer vivre de votre projet ou tout
simplement avoir le budget nécessaire
pour faire évoluer vos idées mais il
faut déjà avoir fait ses preuves
faire ses preuves ça veut dire tout
simplement avoir une communauté et pour
avoir une communauté
il faut donner du contenu donc à partir
de là on va faire une petite ellipses
parce que le thème de la création de
contenu est très très vaste pouvez créer
des webséries des sagas audio des light
novel des mangas enfin plein de choses
sûr qu'il ya des choses ce que j'ai dit
c'est parce que c'est et est donc à
partir de là il est vraiment important
de savoir que ce que vous allez créer
votre premier projet disons que c'est
une web série voilà comme ça c'est un
sujet que je maîtrise premier épisode de
webséries là vous allez vous êtes en
2017 vous allez sortir ça sur internet
donc vous avez plein d'outils sympa vous
avez facebook twitter youtube et c'est
donc là vous allez publier ça vous allez
dire hey salut je suis
créatif je suis plein de motivation et
j'ai créé un truc trop cool
venez voir sauf que des gens comme vous
il y en a des milliers
et votre voix va se perdre dans un
brouhaha constant et incessant et donc
là à partir de là il faut que vous
sachiez qu'à peu près tout ce que vous
allez entreprendre va vous pousser à
abandonner déjà votre premier projet va
peut-être vous avoir pris du temps et là
vous allez sortir vous allez vous dire
ça y est c'est bon c'est le moment et
non vous allez avoir 0 1 ou 2
commentaires ou peut-être quelques
commentaires de jean kévin qui va vous
dire hey c'est nul ça ou alors si
j'avais été toi tu aurais rien publié ça
aurait été mieux donc des choses qui ne
peuvent ou démotivés un petit peu et
puis alors là vous allez vous dire ok
pas de souci je suis plein de motivation
je vais créer une dynamique je vais
créer d'autres épisodes d'autres blogs
bd etc
atika et donc vous allez retourner dans
le processus créatif et là il ya
d'autres embûches qui guette c'est à
dire que vous pouvez avoir votre caméra
par exemple qui va tomber en panne votre
acteur avec qui vous allez peut-être
disputé qui va s'en allait quitter la
série ou votre tablette graphique qui va
tomber en panne donc voilà plein de
choses qui peuvent vous pousser à
abandonner et on va le voir après à ce
stade il est crucial de tenir bon on va
prendre notre exemple en 2001 en 2001 on
a créé la série lost level ce qui était
la première première série pour la
tenter de faire original avec nos
propres personnages notre propre univers
parce qu'avant faisait des parodies
d'univers existants et donc ça nous a
pris sept ans pour faire tous les
épisodes y en a 16 ils font 30 minutes
chacun je vous déconseille d'aller les
voir et sont un peu mieux maintenant et
pendant 7 ans personne n'en n'a rien eu
à faire
personne n'a regardé on n'avait pas de
communauté rien du tout et puis en 2008
on est parti sur un reboot de l'asvel ce
parce que j'en avais pas fini sur le
thème ah oui vous est pas précisée le
thème c'était le mmorpg ça vous avance à
rien c'est les jeux vidéo en fait
massivement multijoueur avec plein de
gens connectés dans un même
environnement
ensuite donc on a créé le reboot qui
s'appelait noble et on ya mis toute
notre expérience on a fait quelque chose
d'un peu plus court
on essaie d'améliorer le rythme et
effets spéciaux etc et puis un beau jour
on est passé de quelques dizaines voire
centaines de vue à 85 millions de vues
actuellement sur internet
ensuite on a eu un award internationale
aux scream awards de los andes
l'ess et puis on a battu le record
d'europe de crohn funding mais c'est
quoi notre secret qu'est ce qui s'est
passé qu'est ce qu'ils on sait pas et
finalement ben nous on n'a rien fait de
particulier
on a juste continuer sans abandonner ce
qui s'est passé ce qui a créé un déclic
ce terreau favorable justement à cette
évolution est totalement indépendant
nous il ya deux choses le premier c'est
la chaîne nolife
pour résumer la chaîne nolife créer du
contenu à ses références et on va dire
c'est une chaîne créée par des geeks
pour des geeks et le deuxième point
c'est le jeu au world of warcraft avec
un accent au top et donc que le vendeur
warcraft c'est un mmorpg donc mmorpg
comme diraient les médias et ce mmorpg a
généré par à fédérer même plusieurs
millions de joueurs à la fois et a rendu
populaire ce genre et donc nous on était
devenus spectateurs de nola effet un
jour on s'est dit et si on allait leur
proposer notre projet nous bhl est la
leur réponse est intéressante
ils nous ont dit bon le thème du mmorpg
nous intéresse et peut donc intéresser
notre public puisque entre temps c'est
devenu populaire
ensuite vous avez le minimum le niveau
minimum requis pour être diffusée sur
une chaîne de télé à cette époque parce
que si vous allez voir les premiers
épisodes vous allez douter de ce que je
viens de dire mais c'était une autre
époque
et puis l'autre point c'est qu'on
termine et nos projets il avait vu avec
lost level ce qu'on était arrivé au bout
de nos projets ils sont 10 bat on vous
fait confiance parce que bon bah vous
avez vous fini vos projets dont il ya
peu de chances que vous me lâcher au
bout de cinq six épisodes qui ont été
dommage parce que c'est quand même une
chaîne de télé fallait que il ya un
minimum de crédibilité
donc on a été diffusée sur nolife ya une
caisse de résonance et l'a vu qu'il ya
des joueurs de world of warcraft cette
fameuse communauté certains sont tombés
sur les épisodes et son 10è c'est sympa
ça me rappelle ce que je fais quand je
joue à world of warcraft et puis je vais
te passer à mon pote et le pote il va
dire je vais le mettre sur mon forum de
guilde et hop les fais du bouche à
oreille et nous a trouvé son public
à ce stade ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que tout ce que vous ferez dans vos
périodes de galère ou d'anonymat n'est
pas inutile
c'est même peut-être fondateur parce que
c'est ce qui va créer le déclic d'une
part donc qui va provoquer votre chance
qui va vous donner aussi les armes de
saisir cette chance si vous ne faites
rien ne se passera rien si on n'avait
pas fait lost level serait pas une
option
fait ces épisodes de lost besson n'a
peut-être pas eu le niveau pour être
diffusée sur la chaîne nolife et si on
n'avait pas fini le projet lost level
peut-être qu'on nous aurait pas fait
confiance parce qu'à la base on était
quand même une bande de copains on
n'était pas une entreprise une boîte de
production ni rien donc ça c'est le
premier point mais une fois que vous
avez saisi votre chance encore faut-il
la garder parce que sur internet ça va
très très vite
le premier point le plus bourré conseil
que je peux vous donner c'est qu'il faut
cultiver sa différence
c'est primordial sur internet prenons
l'exemple des webséries par exemple les
premières web série à avoir une énorme
communauté sont des web séries plutôt
geek donguy que ça veut dire
26 sur cette action jeux vidéo etc ça ce
sont les sources d'inspiration
principale mais pourquoi des webséries
dick ont explosé à cette époque là est
simplement parce que les professionnels
ne maîtrisait pas les codes des web
séries par des oueds pierrick du monde
dit qu'en général on va prendre quelques
exemples qui va peut-être parlé à
certains qui ont peut-être dépenser des
sous pour le cinéma pour voir ce
magnifique film par exemple dragonball
evolution dont je lançais dragon le film
où j'ai un peu sévère mais bon on va
dire tomb raider avec angelina jolie qui
était pas exactement comme le jeu bon ça
ce sont quelques exemples donc nous qui
avions grandi avec ses codes qui était
pas encore maîtrisé par les
professionnels on avait cultivé notre
différence en abordant ce thème et en le
faisant de manière on va dire
respectueuse parce que on a voilà en
conclusion avec grandi avec tout ça donc
on nous pardonner le manque de moyens
mais sur internet comme vous disais tout
va très très vite et ensuite
actuellement d'ailleurs on est en plein
dedans vous allez voir les webséries
s'écroule un petit peu elles ont du mal
à générer des nouvelles communautés les
communautés déjà existantes s'effrite
lentement mais là c'est le problème
inverse
les professionnels ont rattrapé leur
retard et maintenant des contenus qui
plaisent à cette communauté exigeante
que sont les dykes mais ils sont comblés
parce qu'au final par exemple je vais
prendre quelques exemples au cinéma le
seigneur des anneaux plutôt sympa tout
tous les films marvel avec ses crossover
etc
c'est plutôt sympa aussi mais là où
c'est encore plus brillant c'est que les
mecs ils ont réussi à révolutionner
notre manière de consommer la fiction
avec des portails comme netflix ou vous
avez un abonnement vous regardez à
l'infini
des répertoires qui sont sans cesse mise
à jour du coup vous avez alors c'est pas
netflix pour le coup mais bon game of
thrones walking dead mais en prendre
exemple est fixe quand même d'art des
villes voilà donc vous avez plein de
contenus comme ça qu'ils vont vous
satisfaire donc forcément vous aurez
moins de temps pour regarder les vidéos
de comme les web séries fait dans le
jardin avec les copains même si jamais
ça respecte les codes aujourd'hui c'est
un peu dur de lutter quoi donc ça c'est
le point qui fait que sur internet ça va
très vite mais il ya encore de l'espoir
vous inquiétez pas avec nous par exemple
actuellement on s'écroule pas encore
totalement en a sorti une saison 8
ça va plutôt bien je touche du bois à
distance ensuite on a entrepris par une
saison 9
pourquoi est-ce qu'on tient à peu près
pour l'instant mais tout simplement
parce que les professionnels n'ont pas
encore traité le thème du mmorpg en
série live je précise parce que vous
avez des animés japonais des light novel
des mangas mais en séries là il sait pas
encore le cas mais ça va venir parce
qu'ils vont adapter une série qui
s'appelle souvent bart online qui est la
plus grosse en la matière et donc on va
sûrement ils passaient aussi mais bon
c'est pas grave on leur fait qu'une
belle aventure donc les professionnels
ça y est ils arrivent cultiver sa
différence à ne pas forcément dire qu'il
faut avoir le thème qu' aucun
professionnel n'a déjà traité parce que
sinon va pas s'en sortir au bout d'un
moment
donc là on peut aussi cultiver sa
différence en changeant le format par
exemple ok je veux faire un truc de
fantaisie ben je vais peut-être pas
forcément choisir un thème de saint
quentin format de 50 minutes à la game
of thrones pascal derrière il ya une
série à 200 millions quoi donc c'est un
peu compliqué donc peut-être s'est fait
un format un peu court que les gens vont
peut-être pouvoir regarder pendant le
boulot par exemple donc ça c'est plutôt
un bon angle ou alors vous pouvez aussi
avoir je sais pas un angle d'attaqué
différent un angle narratif différents
pour notre part c'est ce qui s'est passé
on a choisi de raconter des histoires
d'une manière qu'on ne savait pas
original en fait puisque on le
pratiquait par mimétisme c'était le
transmédia donc on y revient parce que
le transmédia j'ai toujours pratiqué
sans savoir que ça s'appelait comme ça
en fait j'étais juste fan d'univers
japonais d'univers américain je vais
vous en citer un qui va parler à tout le
monde star wars vous avez la première
trilogie à l'époque la seconde troisième
prennent à 50 milles et vous aviez les
romans les comics vous aviez le dessin
animé chat
chose compléter donc vous aviez le
transmédia qui était déjà bien établies
partout dans le monde sauf en france du
coup non la fée où ils ont fait des
pionniers ouais ben en fait c'est juste
qu'on est super à la bourre les gars
donc en 2008 on a eu la chance de le
pratiquer à l'échelle professionnelle et
en fait on a cultivé notre différence de
cette manière là c'était un atout pour
ma part c'est que je voulais en fait
dépassé ou plutôt contourner de limites
la première c'était nîmes et artistique
avec ma web série je pouvais pas mettre
des dragons qui descendait du ciel en
pourfendant les armées avec des flammes
et tous fassent un peu compliqué en fait
ou alors truc con dragon plastique qui
descend et là on est tout de suite dans
le très très cheap
donc voilà je préférais faire ça plus
tôt en roman est embêtant bande dessinée
du coup c'est mon dessinateur qui
pleurait et donc ça m'a permis de
dépasser cette limite artistique est
donc la nouvelle série tu es plutôt
adressées à la comédie qu'on maîtrisait
un peu plus c'est parce qu'il dit sur
internet mais ça c'est voilà donc
ensuite l'autre limite c'est la limite
économique parce que il était clair que
l'on ne pourrait pas vivre de nouveau en
tant que web série en france on n'est
pas super connu pour nos productions
audiovisuelles de fantaisie de
science-fiction adapté d'adaptations de
jeux vidéo parce qu'il y en a évidemment
vous avez valérian vous allez me dire
eric besson il fait des trucs sympas et
tout oui effectivement mais ce sont des
exceptions donc si c'est rare au cinéma
si c'est rare à la télévision sur
internet ou le modèle économique n'est
absolument pas adapté à sa et qu' il ya
quasiment aucune chance qui un retour
sur investissement de la part
d'investisseurs
il va pas s'amuser à investir dans une
production avec des armures avec des
effets spéciaux des châteaux etc
donc on ne pouvait le faire que en tant
que bénévole donc c'était soit on le
faisait de cette manière soit ça
n'existait pas c'était notre manière à
nous d'exister artistiquement donc ça
c'est un point qui nous a permis de
créer pas mal de contenu mais comme
disait sur internet
c'est très exigeant et il faut aussi
savoir évoluer et se renouveler et donc
là j'arrive et un petit peu aux limites
de ce qu'on était capable de faire après
cinq saisons nous je me suis dit mais
notre modèle économique en
autoproduction risque de nous limiter un
petit peu le scénario
le scénario arrive à un point où si on
file saison 6 dans les conditions
actuelles ça risque de faire vraiment
très très cheap ou alors on change le
scénario mais ça serait dommage
et donc j'ai cherché un autre moyen je
me suis dit messi sans le savoir j'ai
trouvé une solution artistique est un
peu économique avec le transmédia
peut-être qu'il ya d'autres bonnes idées
à l'étranger donc cultiver sa différence
ça ne veut pas forcément dire inventé ça
peut aussi vouloir dire voir ce qui se
passe dans d'autres pays et arsenal à
l'international et l'appliquer dans son
propre pays
et là j'ai découvert le crowdfunding
encore un mot un peu compliqué qui n'a
pas encore tout à fait l'habitude
d'utiliser je pense qu'il y en a qui
connaissent un peu le comte fanning à ce
stade en fait vous voit pas donc j'ai
les lumières mais j'ai entendu quelques
oui donc le crowdfunding c'est le fait
de proposer un projet que vous voulez
faire financer par une communauté les
gens vont décider de participer au
financement
alors ils peuvent recevoir des
contreparties nous par exemple c'était
un film parce qu'au nom du transmédia je
voulais finir ma première époque de noob
sur un long métrage pour me ferais pour
me frotter un petit peu à une autre
forme de narration est donc là on a
dépassé toutes nos attentes puisqu'on
avait demandé un budget de 35 mille et
on nous a confié 680 2000 euros du coup
on s'est dit ok on va carrément faire
une trilogie c'est hollywood c'est parti
donc là on a proposé trois films la
première financiers par internet pour
internet et ça a été une sorte de
bouquet final ça s'est même fini au
grand rex toute cette histoire donc
vraiment c'était assez inespéré tout ça
pour dire que rien de ce qu'on a fait
ces 13 dernières années n'a été inutile
la con accès créer une communauté à
communauté nous a peu à peu porté sur
ses épaules et nous a offert une sorte
de bouquet final extraordinaire mais
quelque part je me dis est ce que ce
qu'on a vécu est ce que notre aventure
n'est pas qu'un exemple qui pourrait
s'adapter à plein d'autres domaines que
le milieu artistique
est ce que finalement il n'y a pas une
évolution notre société à qui on aurait
donné des outils pour prendre des
décisions et pouvoir agir de manière
directe via des outils comme le
crowdfunding comme internet les réseaux
sociaux etc
donc plutôt que de dire si vous voulez
vivre de vos créations sur internet je
dirais plus largement si vous voulez
concrétiser vos projets sur internet
armez vous de votre passion créer des
projets terminés les soumettaient dans
une communauté
n'abandonnez pas cultiver votre
différence parce que tout ce que vous
ferez même pendant vos années de galère
et d'anonymat seront à la fois ce qui
l'a provoqué un déclic
et vous donner les armes pour saisir
votre chance et puis la garder le plus
longtemps possible
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]